considera la siguiente curva de densidad
y esta curva es un poco más sencilla que
las curvas típicas de densidad que hemos
visto hasta el momento que son mas
curvilíneas pero en esta es mucho más
fácil calcular el área y nos piden
encontrar el porcentaje del área bajo la
curva de densidad donde x es mayor que 2
cuál es el área que tenemos aquí cuando
x es mayor que 2 bueno aquí sería el
área cuando x es igual a 2 así que
cuando x es mayor que 2 va a ser esta
área de aquí primero vamos a calcular el
área total que se encuentra por debajo
de esta curva de densidad y esta
densidad sólo va a tener área desde que
x es igual a 1 hasta que x es igual a 3
así que tenemos que encontrar el área de
este trapezoide que estoy señalando y
esta área debe ser igual a 1 ya que el
área bajo la curva de toda la curva de
densidad siempre debe ser igual a 1
vamos a verificarlo hay dos formas en
las que podemos
pensar en esto podemos dividir este
trapezoide en dos formas un rectángulo y
un triángulo o podemos usar la fórmula
para calcular el área de un trapezoide
usemos la fórmula para encontrar el área
de un trapezoidal y esta fórmula toma el
promedio de este lado de aquí y este
lado de acá y ese promedio se multiplica
por el valor de esta base veamos el
promedio de estos lados la altura de
este lado es punto 25 más la altura de
este lado que es de 0.75 y como es
promedio lo vamos a dividir entre 2 con
esto encontramos el promedio de estos
dos lados y esto lo vamos a multiplicar
por la base la longitud de esta base que
es 20 puntos 25 + 0.75 es igual a 1 como
debe ser el área bajo la curva de toda
una curva de densidad siempre debe ser
igual a 1
esta área siempre debe ser igual a 1
para que ésta sea una curva de densidad
ahora calculemos qué porcentaje de esta
área se encuentra representada por esta
sección azul de aquí pues hacemos lo
mismo
este es un trapezoide así que vamos a
promediar la longitud de este lado con
la longitud de este otro lado y lo
multiplicamos por la longitud de la base
así que la altura de este lado es punto
50.5 más la altura de este lado es 0.75
0.75 entre 2 ya que es el promedio y
esto lo multiplicamos por la base y la
base va de 2 a 3 por lo que la longitud
de la base es igual a 1 y esto va a ser
igual a 1.25 entre 2 y esto a que será
igual
1.25 entre 2 va a ser igual a 0.6 25 es
correcto
si si esto lo multiplicó por 2 me va a
dar 1.25 así que el porcentaje del área
bajo la curva de densidad donde x es
mayor que 2 va a ser igual a esto que es
la expresión decimal de este porcentaje
pero si queremos escribirlo como
porcentaje va a ser igual a 60 y 2.5 por
ciento resolvamos otro problema
considera la siguiente curva de densidad
y de nuevo tenemos estas curvas que son
más angulares y nos piden encontrar el
porcentaje del área bajo la curva de
densidad donde x es mayor que 3 aquí
tenemos el 3 y si nos piden el
porcentaje donde x es mayor que 3 pues
va a ser toda esta área de acá
y la respuesta es bastante directa ya
que el área donde x es mayor que 3 es
toda el área bajo la curva de densidad y
el área bajo la curva de toda una curva
de densidad siempre tiene que ser igual
a 1 y cuando nos piden encontrar el área
bajo la curva de densidad donde x es
mayor que 3 pues tenemos toda el área
bajo la curva el 100% así que aquí no
tenemos que molestarnos en calcular el
área bajo esta curva